Pope Francis is the third pope in history...
...to have been chosen by Time Magazine as Person of the Year.
Blessed John Paul II won the honor in 1994 and Blessed John XXIII in 1962.
Time chose Pope Francis this year it said...
...because rarely has a new player on the world stage captured so much attention so quickly...
...from the young, the old, the cynical and the faithful.
It said the pope, with his focus on compassion, has become the new voice of conscience.
Meanwhile, Father Lombardi, the Vatican spokesman,...
...said it's a positive sign that such a prestigious recognition...
...has gone to a person who proclaims spiritual, religious and moral values to the world...
...and speaks effectively in favor of peace and greater justice.
The choice of Pope Francis, the spokesman said, is not surprising...
...in light of his wide appeal and the enormous attention he has attracted.
The spokesman said the pope isn't seeking fame or accolades,...
...but being named Person of the Year will make him happy...
...if it helps attract people to the hope of the Gospel.
Father Lombardi added that the pope would also be pleased...
...if the magazine's decision means that many have understood this message of hope.